do you believe that president Trump is
gonna stand by you throughout I know
he's gonna stand by me called me this
afternoon sites standing by me we're
still covering the battle over Brett
Kavanaugh as nomination the Supreme
Court which most people assumed would
not be difficult it has turned out to be
very difficult and it's exposing fault
lines and ideas that some of us are not
familiar with we want to get to the
bottom of what they are Kristy Setzer as
president of new heights communications
and she joins us tonight
so Kristy mazie Hirono said something
remarkably played it twice on this show
no one else seems amazed by it she's a
sitting - a senator of course from
Hawaii and she said that men all men are
implicated in sexual assault and women
all women must be believed because
they're women that seems like an idea
that would cut against the Western
understanding of justice I'm not sure
that that's exactly what she said but I
do think there's something particular
about crimes of sexual assault and
accusations of sexual assault and that
is that it's the one crime at least that
I can think of in which the presumption
the burden of proof is on the woman to
say that she really is a victim so last
year I had my car stolen when I reported
it it was I was not asked well what did
you do wrong to allow your car to be
stolen right Jerry did she ever ask
questions like what no did you leave
your keys in the car I mean of course
you were now sexual assault is a more
delicate issue for obvious reasons yes
but do you think that our standards of
justice change in other words is the
burden of proof lower yeah do you
believe in the idea that a person is
innocent until proved guilty we see
lawmakers challenging that idea I do but
again there's something very particular
about cases of sexual assault and rape
which is that for one thing the vast
majority of women never come forward and
there's lots of reasons for this one is
basically about how difficult it would
get it is to get to trial or to get to a
conviction one another reason is just
all the issues around shame and then a
final reason is
some of the things that are playing out
with Kavanagh which is peculiar issues
around memory when we're talking about
traumatic events so all of that is true
and of course there this is a recovered
memory we now know that came out in
psychotherapy doesn't mean it's false
does mean there are a lot of instances
where recovered memory was false and
innocent people went to prison it
happened quite a bit in the 80s around
the satanic abuse ritual scares you know
I'm not saying this is like that but I
am saying it means the rest of us have
to ask real questions about it you seem
to be suggesting the standards ought to
be different that we should give her the
presumption of honesty yeah and that's
not how our justice system works is it
yeah I mean I think it's important for
you and for your viewers to know the
context of it which is that there's no
more instances of false accusations
around say rape and and similar crimes
as there is for any other crime and I
think that we I'm not I'm not saying it
well then I'm not saying I'm not saying
otherwise I am saying there's a much
higher incidence of false memory in
recovered memory cases than in
conventional cases that's true and it's
been looked at extensively by social
scientists and I don't think any debate
about that doesn't mean this is false
but it means that if you want justice if
that's your goal then you have to ask
hard questions but again I don't
understand have we changed the standards
or haven't we see all these members of
Congress saying he's a man he's guilty
she's a woman you must believe for you
saw exactly actually here's what
Blumenthal saying the onus is on him to
prove he's innocent right is that our
system works it's I thought was the
opposite of how it worked yeah again the
reason is that because he has said it
absolutely didn't happen fabrication
right this isn't a criminal trial but it
is something in which he is asking for a
very large promotion to the Supreme
Court of the United States right so you
want somebody who has impeccable
character whose motive absolutely could
not be questioned and he's given us
nothing but doubt throughout these kind
of hold our weight sort of joints with
the principle leaving Cavanaugh aside
because these are lawmakers mm-hmm
they're the most powerful people in our
society they determine what our laws are
by definition they're saying that the
accused has an obligation and has a
responsibility to come forward with
evidence to rebut the claims mm-hmm that
is again precisely the opposite of
English common law which our system is
based
no one has ever said that before that
I'm aware of in the history of my living
history anyway and you're okay with that
yeah what I think should happen is
actually what both dr. Ford and and now
Ramirez believe should happen which is
that there should be an FBI and that's
what are you but he's saying judge
Kavanagh has a responsibility to come
forward the evidence to rebut the
charges do you or don't you think that's
a fair standard i I do think that yes if
we're gonna have this conversation about
whether or not these things happen and
he doesn't want an FBI investigation
which by the way he does not then sure
yes he wanted to accuse you of something
with no physical evidence or
eyewitnesses which is what she has done
from 36 years ago and it's a sex crime
that would destroy your reputation and
hurt your family you now have a moral
obligation or a responsibility as
senator from Connecticut says to rebut
that is that's what you're saying you
have an obligation yes to defend
yourself now again he has decided that
he doesn't want an FBI investigation
that's the Republican Party had said and
that they also don't you used has a
responsibility and you can't find
evidence to disprove the charge which
has no evidence to support it in the
first place then you are presumed guilty
if anybody's saying that he's going to
go to jail no they're saying maybe he
won't be a Supreme Court judge I mean
he's actually little girls and a wife
and he's being accused of a sex crime by
someone who has zero evidence it
happened and multiple witnesses who say
it didn't and now we're saying that this
guy has to prove that he's innocent you
really want to live in that country
honestly your question yeah no since
your since your answer which is that I
think that right now there is a very
disproportionate sense of justice for
women who have come forward with these
crimes and I think that right now we
tend not to believe them and I think
that all that senator Hirono and others
are saying is that maybe sometimes we if
we've learned anything from say than me
to movement it's that these things
happen
all over the time and we should believe
with them sort of false claims I was a
subjective one of them so I can tell you
a lot about that if you're interested
maybe later Christy thank you thank you
jack